you know they they don't seem to
fact-check joe biden in pennsylvania
yesterday
or the day before when he says i'm not
against fracking i'm like
well here's you on that same debate
stage joe saying that you'd eliminate
fossil fuels that you said no new
fracking here's you talking to another
woman saying
we're going to eliminate it all i mean
there's 50 clips of him saying exactly
the opposite but
because fracking is an important issue
in pennsylvania that is a swing state
the media will literally run with the
lie there
where it's more of a sensitive issue
they'll run with exactly the opposite
and pretend as though both of them are
true just depending on who they're
selling to
you know they're not fact checking this
is an egregious lie there's tape all
over the place not one fact check called
him out on it
not one social media site took him down
for dishonesty they let him run the clip
as though it's true
let's just do the kamala thing here for
a minute because
were you guys when i say you guys the
trump
organization the the campaign your dad
what was the feeling when when it came
out that it was kamala because
on one hand i think she's probably not
as full say communist marxist whatever
that bernie thing is
but as you just pointed out her voting
record is pretty
far left and she's an authoritarian you
know she
she did that line that line that i keep
bringing up in the debate
where they asked biden you know will you
do an executive action on guns and he
said well anything i would do would have
to be constitutional
which of course is the right answer and
she looked at him and laughed in his
face
and now this is the person who is now
his vp how did you guys feel about the
choice
you know i i listen i i sort of think
it's a great thing right because
you you know where her record is i mean
she's literally left of bernie in voting
records she doesn't care about those
sorts of things as you've said it's
uh so she's also so disingenuous she's
just
you know you see that she's a phony it's
just been pure ambition for her whole
life and you know that's
that's not a terrible trait but it is
when you basically sell out all of your
principles to get there so for us
i think it's actually a great choice but
the media also agrees because the media
also wanted her to be
number one that's who they were pushing
for from moment number one now she's
terrible in the stage she's not so
warm she's you know just a terrible
candidate really
but for us i love it because everyone
believes she's the one that's going to
be in charge
uh you know it's sort of you know joe
biden picking her after she
now i got fact checked for this they
told me that i was they threw me off
instagram for this one because i said
she called him a racist and she said to
believe his sexual assault accusers
because again
remember when someone accuses joe biden
even though there's corroborating
evidence much more so
that doesn't count only those who accuse
trump of something with much with no
evidence
with no corroboration with all nonsense
you know that's to be believed but when
it happens to joe biden from a senate
staffer no no nothing to see here
but she did those things and you saw her
absolutely demolish him
on the debate stage as it related to his
racial decisions and his history there i
get into that in the book a lot
but i said well she called him a racist
and she said to believe his sexual
assault
accusers so of course it gets fact
checked well she didn't call him a race
cycle what do you mean
they go well she didn't say the words
racist i go yeah but she went on a five
minute diatribe about how he supported
bussing how he partied with
segregationists how he'd
i mean she did literally everything but
no reasonable person in the world would
assume
that she meant anything other than yeah
i think joe biden's a racist but they
can fact-check you as false
uh you know they they don't seem to
fact-check joe biden in pennsylvania
yesterday
or the day before when he says i'm not
against fracking i'm like
well here's you on that same debate
stage joe saying that you'd eliminate
fossil fuels that you said no new
fracking here's you talking to another
woman saying
we're going to eliminate it all i mean
there's 50 clips of him saying exactly
the opposite but
because fracking is an important issue
in pennsylvania that is a swing state
the media will literally run with the
lie there
where it's more of a sensitive issue
they'll run with exactly the opposite
and pretend as though both of them are
true just depending on who they're
selling to
you they're not fact checking this is an
egregious lie there's tape all over the
place not one fact check called him out
on it
not one social media site took him down
for dishonesty they let him run the clip
as though it's true it's on his platform
just go look at his website so
again part of the whole thing that's
liberal privilege you can have
the best of all worlds it doesn't matter
what the truth is
it doesn't matter we are going to sell
to the american public whatever it is
that they want to hear
to be able to effectuate the change that
they want with just to put joe biden in
office
or whoever his puppet masters really are
so is the best example of that
the exact video that biden launched his
campaign with
which was the charlottesville video and
he is basically saying your dad is
supporting white supremacist when of
course
and no matter how many times we talk
about this it never makes it to
mainstream media
a sentence before your dad said find
people on both sides and of course what
he meant was of the statue debate
but he completely condemned the kkk and
the white supremacists and the neo-nazis
and everything else
but the media ran cover for biden on
that so in biden's mind or whatever is
left of it he was just like all right
well
i can just keep running online hey why
not run with it i mean
they'll do whatever it takes to win it's
no problem right that's that's what
they're gonna do by the way they brought
that up at the dnc
multiple times as though literally
you're right the first sentence
led up to it so it was clear before it
wasn't like he made a mistake and
recovered
it was very clear to begin with they
play one portion of the clip and then
they talk
they forget about the second sentence
which was and of course i'm condemning
the white supremacists and the crazy
people that were there because it wasn't
all that
but they run with it as though it's the
gospel i mean it's the same thing in the
media
they're still running dave with russia
collusion
they're still pretending like that's a
real thing notice how
no one has any interest in like looking
into comey and the fbi and obama and
biden himself
unmasking us it's the first time we've
had a non-peaceful transition of power
a great great great american tradition
for 240-something years
nothing to see here folks now it was a
big deal for three years when they
thought it worked the other way
when it worked against trump when when
they could do that i mean you see the
testimony of these clowns
i mean under oath they say x on cnn
later that day they say
exactly the opposite because no one's
going to hold them accountable they know
it's not true because they're literally
under oath saying the opposite but guess
what we get a cnn job
how about you know the comeys and the
mccabe some these guys lied to congress
uh well you know it's really bad you
shouldn't lie to congress but nothing to
see i'd be in jail if i lied to congress
they get paid big bucks to then be a cnn
contributor i mean they're rewarded
for treason they're awarded for lying to
the country and to the american people
that's sort of what we're up against and
again that's why i i took it upon myself
to do this book when i had no intention
to do it because
i've been a part of it i've you know if
you didn't believe in the deep state if
you didn't believe in sort of
these big government things prior to
2016
you know what i get it if you don't now
if you think that these people are truly
just trying to represent you and they're
not just taking care of themselves
you're out of your mind look at what my
father's trying to do you know pulling
troops out of afghanistan ending these
never-ending wars then our own generals
can't even tell us why we're there
anymore
you know they start leaking opposition
research trump is getting soft on russia
what
there's more sanctions on russia than
any in any administration in american
history
but they do that because they want to
stay in endless wars because they don't
care about sending
nice kids from middle america to go lose
life and limb abroad so they can keep
the military-industrial complex going
and that's not just democrats that
they're a big part of it but it's also
the neocons
and sort of the never trump republicans
that hate that he's getting out you know
why
because they want to be on the board of
raytheon for 500 000 a year
they'll do whatever it takes they'll get
their board seat they'll do that all of
their friends get rich
sending our kids to die for something
that we don't even know why we're there
and it never ends trump tries to pull
out of these things
and you literally have people in
congress trying to literally
stop him from doing it uh and it's so
obvious
and yet again nothing to see here folks
if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell